Now we're going to set
up a simple project, so
we can experiment with presenting
stock view controllers.
You're probably familiar with views like
the Camera Roll, Activity Views, and
Alert Views.
These are off the shelf view controllers
which we'll present without modifying
Apple's code.
To get some practice with presenting
off the shelf view controllers,
we'll make a one button app
with a method named experiment,
which presents one of
Apple's view controllers.
It'll look something like this.
One button which presents
the camera roll, and
the experiment method will
look something like this.
In this method we'll need a reference
to the view controller we're
about to present.
So how will we get that
view controller reference?
We'll just make one.
So here we invoke the constructor for
the view controller required to select
an image, and then in this line,
we present the image picker.
Now see if you can repeat
this experiment on your own.
Just create a single view project
with a button labeled Present, and
then connect that button to
an action named experiment.
If you get stuck, consult
the steps in the instructor notes.
But first try to complete
it without peeking.
Again, your app should
look something like this.
When you're finished,
describe your level of confidence
working through this exercise.